when you talk about that defense fill in
this blank for me okay
being defended by jabari smith
feels like
[Music]
a bad dream
a nightmare
[Music]
hello jabari what's up what's up thanks
for being here hey how are you doing oh
my gosh i already iced out
no
hey i feel i feel like that's a rite of
passage uh in the nba yeah something
like that yeah so i believe and correct
me if i'm wrong this is your first like
real sit-down interview as an nba player
uh yeah it is actually yeah my first one
yeah i'm sure there's been a bunch of
media that you're like a lot of media
yeah how how are you feeling about
having to like there's always something
to do always a question to answer
um i mean i feel like i've been dealing
with it fine you know it was kind of
kind of like that in college but now
it's like a whole nother level you know
asking
now they're looking for a story kinda
now they like the questions kind of
deeper so it's just it's just kind of
different yeah like a little bit of an
investment yeah well i mean i'm happy to
have you here i get really excited
whenever we have a georgia person on the
show cause i'm from gwinnett county
um you're from fayetteville um so i
actually want to start in georgia i want
you to tell me about crab apple
elementary school um that's really like
an elementary school where
it's like real close to my high school
it's not too far and basically it's like
elementary school and they got like a
full court outside
and uh kind of like when kova hit no
gyms was open or nothing like that so
um anytime i wasn't with my dad in the
gym like i'll go back home like with my
friends and that was the only thing that
was open was that so we just started
making it kind of a thing and then when
kobe ended like we just kept going and
it kind of ended up being like a little
chill spot for us
so but the court that you guys would
play on there the it was an eight-foot
hoop right the the 10-foot goal was next
to it but on the other one it was eight
foot so it's like
my friends would want to play on the
shorter one so they could dunk and all
of that you know what i'm saying but i
still wanted to play so i still play
every now and then i wouldn't be like
odin but i'll still play yeah and so
then crab apple kind of became like the
identity of the group right i think i
read that you all's fantasy football
league also became called crabapple
which by the way have you ever won your
favorite no i've never won number one
really you're very upset about it i
always always be consistent like the
first like six weeks like always
checking my lineup and then after i'll
just be like let it go oh it like falls
off for you really stop checking it i
don't know why i'm gonna be consistent
this year yeah okay so if you had to
build like your dream fantasy football
team tell me who your quarterback is two
wide receivers and two running backs
all right you said quarterback um i'm
gonna pick mike vick
okay from atlanta so mike vick you said
running back
um
my favorite running back growing up was
reggie bush even though he played for
the saints it was like still kind of my
fault yeah i was gonna say we're not
allowed to like them but it was like it
was like i still liked him just because
who he was his college story and all
that so yeah reggie bush you said two
high receivers um julio jones of course
and i would say calvin johnson yeah were
you heartbroken when julio left atlanta
i really was yeah i was it kind of hurt
a little bit i mean he's my favorite i'd
still be rooting for him though i wanted
to win really yeah
we all we all want the best work how did
you feel about matt ryan leaving um it
was kind of like bittersweet because a
lot of people didn't like him but like
he was there for so long and like he was
like quarterback for such a long time it
was like
i'm gonna miss you but it's time for
somebody yeah yeah it was it was time to
go yeah yeah i mean i don't know
everything you know so yeah i don't know
how mariota is going to be but fingers
crossed because i i want the falcons to
be to be really good again
yeah all right so here in vegas summer
league what do you think summer league
has shown you about your game so far um
it's showing me that i can affect the
game and a lot
in a lot more ways than scoring i would
say my first two games i didn't shoot
the ball well i didn't i wasn't scoring
the ball well but i feel like i impacted
the game in other ways such as like
defense and rebounding and just
encouraging my teammates and just kind
of leading but um i feel like that's
what i learned most just
just other ways i can affect the game
and separate myself really i think that
for some fans when they're watching
summer league since the first time
they're seeing their new guys on the
court they have like very crazy
reactions just because they're like okay
this is the first time and i don't know
what i'm getting how do you stay
level-headed in a game in summer league
when it's maybe not going exactly how
you want it to um it's easy when you got
a great coaching staff and great
teammates who are always uplifting you
who who've seen what you can do and
seeing what you're capable of it's like
the outside noise really doesn't matter
it's like we're all a unit and we're all
the group and we're all trying to get
better together so it's like what other
people are saying it really doesn't it
really doesn't matter to me it's like
i know that every game i feel like i've
played better i've been more aggressive
and like that's the only thing that
really matters we've played better every
game and we're winning so i'm happy yeah
and i think you have shown some really
good stuff this summer league and you're
right every game has been better than
the last
what do you attribute you know those
mini jumps to between each game just
settling in like even when i was in
college like if you go look at the stats
you look at the numbers like my first
few games wasn't wasn't wasn't great you
know what i'm saying but when i figure
it out and find my niche and find my
find my rhythm i feel like that's what
i'm playing best that's when i'm that's
when i'm having fun with the game and
just just just playing playing better
so one of the things that's always
really interesting about you know
rookies coming in is you are watching
the nba before you're in the nba so you
have thoughts on teams before you join
those teams
so before you were part of the rockets
when you were watching that team what
did you feel like they needed to improve
and how do you bring some of those
things um i feel like they just needed
defense for the most part um you know
they were they're very talented
offensively you know you can't take that
from away from them with kpj and jalen
green and
alpy you know like the offense is is not
the concern but at the same time they
wanted somebody who who can bring
defense and and and lead that defensive
unit so i feel like that's what i kind
of bring you know what i mean still
going to be learning from still going to
be having my ears open but i really want
to come in from day one and just set
that tone on defense really yeah
absolutely okay and we're going to get
into you defensively because many people
believe you were the best defensive
player in uh this past draft but i want
to talk about draft night a little bit
i remember after the draft you talked
about telling your friends you weren't
going to cry but then you saw your mom
and dad crying and you couldn't help it
what about their tears moved you um just
the sacrifices they've made everything
we've been through everything we've
we've been through always staying
together so like for with for them being
with me on that night and them really
showing their emotions like really
really let it all out for me because
like i wouldn't be here without them
like the sacrifices they made
everything they they put on the line for
me it's like i'm finally here and i
finally can pay them back you know what
i mean so it kind of kind of came out
for me yeah you know i feel like it's
something that no one really gets until
they have a kid like i don't understand
it but
it's crazy to think about this person
that you made
eventually goes out and like lives this
dream that they've been talking about
for their entire life so the draft night
is really really special for for parents
too what did you say to them right after
the moment um i just told them thank you
told them i love them and it's just the
beginning you know i mean like
the a new journey starts like i tell my
dad like it's time to amp up the work
the work ethic time to amp it up a
little bit and it's just time to start a
new chapter in my life so just told him
i thank him
uh and i love them really yeah so what
emotion did you feel when you heard your
name called at number three
um i felt kind of surprised because you
know all the mock drafts and stuff me
talking to other teams like i thought i
would go higher but
you know when it happened it's like all
the emotions and the frustrations i had
when my name wasn't called first or
second it was like it all went out the
window because at the end of the day i
just achieved my lifelong dream and when
the commissioner said my name is like so
many emotions just left my body and it
was all positive you know what i mean so
that's kind of how i felt but um
i was i was just really surprised you
know i wasn't really mad at it it was
just more of a surprise and a shock to
me you know i mean because the two
players before me like they're great you
know i mean nothing against them but it
just felt surprising to me so yeah all
of my emotions just kind of was was
running at the time yeah so surprised
her when you heard your name at three
but what's the emotion you felt when you
didn't hear your name at one um
like i said surprise but at the same
time i was just like
um okay that team didn't want me you
know what i mean move on then the next
team didn't want me but when the team
finally caught my name it was like i got
to go into this situation and just give
them my all because they took a chance
on me when other teams didn't you know
what i mean so just got to give them all
was that moment as crazy for you
as it was for all of us working or
watching because it was like all of a
sudden everything changed
was it was it that kind of it was
definitely crazy like i was over here
shaking like that was the first time i
ever like
felt like you know when people say i was
shaking like i was really shaking i
couldn't like stop you know i mean just
because
i didn't know where i was where i was
gonna go because i thought i was gonna
go one and two i didn't go one or two so
who knows what if i don't go three you
know i mean like it was just so many
emotions and so many
so many possibilities in my head but you
know my name was called it was like like
i said everything just left my body and
it was like all positive yeah and the
interesting thing too about the draft
it's like everyone is so hyper focused
on the players so you're probably
sitting there shaking and feeling away
but you also know all the cameras are on
you too so you're trying to hide it in
some ways have you re-watched the draft
like have you watched that moment of
yourself um yeah it comes on tv every
now and then so
i see it and i see like how my face was
and and all of that so it's just like
every time i see it the emotion comes
back and i just think about it and it
kind of motivates me a little bit yeah
has anyone like from after that happened
has anyone from orlando like reached out
to you oh no but
but you know i can see like you know
like in the tunnels and stuff when we
get ready for some of these games i see
some of the people i was with like when
i visit them so i say hey to him see how
they're doing you know ask him and um
just just still interacting with him you
know they know you know her feelings
like throw a side eye yeah for sure
i still see him i saw the um
vice president for okc the head coach
for okc talk to him and just caught up
with him they told me congratulations
and all of that so it was all good so no
side eye and no bad blood but you've
talked about having a chip on your
shoulders so when you play orlando will
it feel a little different for you
personally it definitely feels a little
different they know that yeah
like everybody knows that so it's like
nothing i really have to push or not
like that it's just like it's just
something that's going to be in the back
of my head but at the end of the day i'm
still trying to go in there and win so
so i mean i i just want to say this as
somebody who obviously like works in the
media and i understand how
sometimes narratives work and they will
follow players
you know that for
the beginning of your career people
always tie you and paulo together yeah
even though that's silly and even though
it's ridiculous but they will always
point to this and they'll talk about who
made the right decision you know orlando
houston whatever the case may be um and
i feel like that's not fair because you
are bigger than whatever draft night is
for you
so for any fans what do you want them to
remember about you on draft night um i
want them to remember
just
how happy i was after i got picked you
know what i mean like when i got drafted
i feel like my face wasn't didn't show
my my true emotion at the time like i
was still kind of
kind of frustrated a little bit and
surprised but when i got picked i was
real happy to to be a houston rocky you
know i mean like
i was just so motivated and so ready to
work it was like it was crazy you know
what i mean so that's kind of what i
want people to know remember yeah the
happiness that came from knowing i mean
you're in the nba greatest life yeah
third overall effect okay so everyone
always calls the greatest night of their
life which i obviously believe it is but
they also say by the end of the night
you're so tired
were you just dead after yeah you
drained you know what i mean start from
early from you
doing whatever you do in the morning and
then you gotta
um
go to the luncheon with the commissioner
then you got to go back to your room get
ready for draft night take a shower do
all of that
then you're like on the bus and then
when you get there you got to wait in
the waiting room it's like it's a lot
it's a lot of steps to it
but then like after it happens you gotta
talk to
a thousand people then you gotta
take pictures it's a lot it's a lot
going on
after after all of that you gotta
celebrate with your friends and family
and then the night don't end until
whenever in and then it's like the next
morning
gotta get on the flight yeah out of here
so you're right
yeah no i love that i'm so excited to be
able to watch you play for the rockets
this season um but so i watched a
feature that you did with br hoops
and in it you're talking about pressure
and you're saying that all of pressure
is mental
you know now that you have all these
expectations around you third overall
pick bright lights young team
do you feel pressure
um
definitely you know i mean pressure's
something that i feel like i've been
feeling like i said in the in the video
since high school since i was ranked
number six in the country like all eyes
are on you at all times you know what i
mean like expectations are gonna be high
but that's something i work for you know
i ain't work to like
be low in the drive for nothing like
that you know what i mean like i'm here
for a reason and i'm gonna show them
here for a reason so that's kind of how
i think about it but at the same time
you can't think about it and you know
that if you know that you put in the
work and you know that you're being your
best self there's nothing to really be
be mad about no matter what critics say
no matter what anybody says yeah so but
when you talk about feeling the pressure
right it's pressure to
what
just pressure to
live up to
expectations you know i mean like
everybody wants me to
come in and
basically be what they saw in college
you know what i mean like
every like they picked me somehow for a
reason because i did what i did in
college than what i did in high school
so it's like they're they're expecting
to see the same thing and if they see
something different that's when they
label you as different things like busts
and all of that you know what i mean so
it's just it's just
just putting in the work and knowing
that you're working and knowing that you
maximize your potential then
you can be happy with yourself it don't
really matter what nobody else is saying
for sure so when you talk about you know
the pressure of the expectations you
feel like people have put on you
what are the expectations you have put
on yourself um
for now or just in general in basketball
in general in basketball and for now
like what are the expectations for your
rookie season for my rookie season i
just want to come in and like i said
impact winning you know i mean not
necessarily score a certain amount of
points
do all of that but i just want to
be a big asset to my team you know i
mean i want to be somebody who's playing
a lot of minutes somebody who's in the
game late in the game you know like just
somebody who who
is very important piece to my team you
know i mean whether that's defense
whether that's offense whatever it is
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be happy with it
and i feel like if that's happening i
feel like we're going to be winning
games so
just just winning games and overall
making the playoffs overall winning
rookie of the year so those are my goals
yeah i'm sorry i actually i love like
every single person that night was like
i'm rookie of the year i'm like oh we
got a lot of rookie of the years and
what do you think will separate you in
that race for rookie of the year um both
sides of the ball like i feel like i
i can i can score and i can
and i love defense like defense is
something that i pride myself on
something that
um i focus on going into every game like
that's my main priority it's stopping my
man stopping up the opposing team so i
feel like me being able to play so both
sides of the ball at a high level will
be my case for rickety yeah so that is
one thing about you you get excited
about defense which is rare in the nba
nobody really wants to play defense in
the nba how do you feel like you will
avoid that
that allure of focusing on the
flashiness the offensive you know
basketball um i feel like i won't i
won't have no problem adjusting because
like that's just kind of who i am like
i'm not no flashy you know i'm saying
no flashy person so it's like i don't
got no problem with doing dirty work i
don't got no problem with
with doing the little things that that
helped win it you know what i mean so
um
i feel like it won't be an adjustment
for me but at the same time
it is a lot of cameras it is a lot of
people in the stands so
you know just just kind of kind of
locking in and focusing yeah but defense
does win the game and i think that's
what's interesting whenever people talk
about you know you being on that team as
the raucous didn't necessarily need more
offense which you alluded to but what
they needed was that defender right
somebody who's going to help space the
floor and that's exactly what you do as
well so but when you talk about that
defense fill in this blank for me okay
being defended by jabari smith
feels like
a bad dream
a nightmare nightmare it's just like
like
i'm not the quickest but when you get by
me i'm 6 10 so you're gonna have to
finish you're gonna have to find
something to do with it and it's like i
do have good feet so it's like
it's just it's just kind of tough and
when i get when i get stronger when i
get even quicker it's like it's going to
be even more scary so i'm excited so you
want the guys to have nightmares about
you switching on to them in that game
okay
i love that so you obviously you have
the ability to guard one through five
what type of player do you think gives
you
the biggest problems on defense
um what type of players i feel like
um
ones that
i would say shooters for the most part
people that can really shoot from deep i
would say because that forces me to
press up into you a little bit more
really really slide my feet really
moving my feet so i would say if you can
really shoot really have a quick trigger
i feel like that's gonna be the hardest
part i wouldn't say somebody really
attacking me as much because i feel like
i can hold my ground you know what i'm
saying contest contest late with my
length so i feel like somebody who who's
a really good shooter from distance
meant forcing me to press up and i feel
like that's where it would get probably
tough for me who are you most excited to
defend excited to defend i would say
most excited to defend lebron and most
and most excited would probably be steph
lebron and steph yeah oh i mean that now
you talk about the shooters steph is
like going to pick him up
half court no that's going to be really
fun what do you think that uh that
matchup will look like um he's gonna get
my best shot he and
and i'm gonna get his best shot so we're
gonna see how i go yeah so when your dad
talks about your defense he says i wanna
make sure i say it right he said there's
another level to it
what do you think he means by that um
like i said pressing up into the ball
more i feel like right now i still give
people space because i know i'm long i
know i can contest late but
when i start playing against the luca
dances and
the the steph's and the kyrie's like you
can't let them shoot the shots that you
know i mean i would let somebody in
college shoot
or you know any regular person shoot so
it's like
when i when i'm able to press up into
the ball and really give those guys
trouble it's gonna be really really
tough that's what i'm gonna be guarding
the best player every night gonna be
guarding
like the opposing team's best scorer
every night so when he says another
level i feel like it he means that and
also me getting stronger me being able
to guard like the bigger people you know
i mean like joel embiid and
all of those guys like giannis and all
of them so it's just like you said
another level to it and obviously
progression is progression and that
happens in the time that it should but
when do you feel like you see that other
level when do you hope to see it um i
feel like i hope to see it when the
season starts you know i mean i got a
lot of time to prepare a lot of time to
get my body stronger get a lot of time
to mature and learn more about this game
so by the time the season starts i feel
like i should be
like all defensive team caliber like
from day one really yeah one thing i've
heard you talk about a lot in your
interviews is being a hard worker um
which i mean there's a thing i think a
lot of people say right i work hard i
like to be in the gym whatever you know
we all feel like we are hard workers but
what do you feel like makes you a hard
worker um
i feel like it was just kind of
i feel like
it's kind of how i was raised like
um my approach every day is like kind of
different like if i
if i finish a practice or a workout and
feel like i didn't like exert myself or
i didn't feel like i worked hard enough
i feel like i'm gonna do more like all
the time like i'm
always working so i feel like i've
satisfied myself for today you know what
i mean like
like if it's an off day i'm not just
going to be laying around and like
enjoying my off day i got to go do
something you know i got to get better
in some way whether that's even watching
film whether that's
going to the gym and shooting shots not
even really going hard or intense just
just getting better in some way that's
kind of how i was raised what do you
anticipate you know your off season
looking like
my office is looking like a lot of
lifting a lot of getting stronger um a
lot of
just a lot really like a lot of getting
in shape a lot of just learning about
the game learning from my teammates at
training camp and just just filling out
this system and this offense and this
and this and this culture really yeah
absolutely and i mean i assume like do
you already know what houston is going
to look like for you know where you're
living you know all these things um i
have an idea where i'm living at but i
haven't i haven't um pulled the trigger
on nothing yet so i'm still looking
right now is this going to be
like the first time you've like fully
lived alone um in college you know i
mean i had a roommate but um my parents
wasn't with me so like i was alone but
this would be the first time i'm really
like alone yeah like a like a grown-up
yeah that's what i always think just
about this stage in rookies lives it's
like so much is changing for you
really really quickly and i'm sure it
can feel like a lot how have you dealt
with just like this major life change um
it's been it's it's been kind of not
tough but like kind of different what i
mean because
like
you don't have
um your parents with you a lot you don't
have
your like you don't have somebody like
holding your hand a little bit you know
i'm saying like in college i feel like
that was my first time really like
getting away and i feel like i did fine
like i was taking care of myself i still
was working hard but
like at this level it's kind of
different because you know i don't know
campus like you're in a real
city like things can happen like
you got to keep yourself safe like
different things like that come into
play and it's like it's kind of
different you know what i mean and a lot
more people know you than in college so
it's just kind of different do you feel
like you know as someone who has had
bright lights on them for a large chunk
of their life that you almost had to you
had to grow up really fast or at least
mature really fast definitely not
and like i alluded to earlier like just
just how i was raised like i wasn't baby
you know what i'm saying like
like my parents let me
let me grow up you know i mean it wasn't
like i said
holding my hand or
or just forcing themselves upon me like
they let me grow up they gave me my
space and i feel like that makes me who
i am today like makes me more mature it
makes me more
like um self-dependent kind of so i
thank them for that but at the same time
like if i'm in the wrong they're gonna
let me know and they always gonna make
sure i'm doing the right thing and
and always watching me no your dad he
stopped playing basketball to focus on
being your dad
what conversations have you had with him
about that decision he made um
he just
i've kind of told him that like i have
to put my all into the game just because
he sacrificed so much to to be in my
life because you know he grew up without
a father figure so
him being in my life him him going out
his way to be in my life is real big for
me so
i feel like i owe him that to just pay
him back and just
just go hard for him
who's the one person whose opinion you
value over all others
ah
probably his you know what i mean even
if i do
even if i go with his opinion or don't
go with his opinions i was going to be
in the back of my mind like
like he said do this you know i mean
like
sometimes i agree sometimes i don't but
at the end of the day it's always going
to be my dad said this so if i don't go
with it and i'm wrong it's like next
time i need to listen to my dad you know
what i'm saying but and that's just
being me being 19 is like you know you
know how i go yeah for sure and i know i
mean obviously he played such a major
role in how you play basketball do you
ever hear his voice like as you're
playing oh all the time like
any time i'm doing something wrong like
i know what he was saying so it's like
it's easy for me to fix it you know what
i mean and i and i thank him for that
like i thank him for being at my games
yelling when i was younger like now i
can like kind of hear him without him
even doing it like i can hear what he
would be saying and i could hear the
adjusting the adjustments that he would
want me to make yeah okay give me an
example um for instance like on defense
he always emphasizes me having my hands
out me always
being big and using my long arm so
anytime i'm on defensive my hands down
and like a ball is it swung past me and
my hands aren't up maybe i could have
like deflected it i'll think like
immediately like i got to get my hands
up i know he was probably mad about that
so like the next so the rest of the game
my hands out my hands like active so
that's something i kind of focus on so
you're just hearing him hands up yeah
i know july 1st you all were supposed to
play one final one-on-one game he pushed
it back he didn't even play me
he didn't play me because he blamed it
on like me not getting hurt or nothing
like that but
he said august first now so we're gonna
see oh but you're like nah you push it
back because he was about to get you
know why he pushed it
but the last time you all played you won
right yes okay by how much like large
martial yeah it was a large margin okay
we ain't gonna put your daddy on blast
but just know you won
okay this is completely random but i was
just wondering this so i know your
high school was a little upended by kova
it's not final year for you so you
didn't get to do mcdonald's all-american
game didn't they get to do jordan
classic
did you get to do things like did you
have a prom
um
no no i didn't have a problem i took
prom pictures and stuff but our prom was
held in the cafeteria so i didn't really
i didn't go oh okay but so you went
junior year you're saying um you know
junior it got shut down by cobra too
because that was like when i was a
junior the culver thing hit around march
and i promised supposed to be in like i
want to say maybe april or may yeah so
that one was cut and then senior year
everything was getting back to normal
like towards the end but they didn't
have it like no you know big place and
like that it was just like we're going
to do in the cafeteria and i was like no
you're like no
i'm good yeah because i mean i was
thinking about the things things that
you would miss out on because things
that got shut down but it seems like you
don't you weren't like it doesn't matter
it was some things like the mcdonald's
game definitely hurt me you know i mean
problem kind of hurt too because it's
like in my junior i was gonna go like
when i went my junior i was saying
if this if it's not what it's what it
seems or if it's not like fun i'm not
gonna go my senior year but my junior
year i'ma go but um when it got shut
down it was like
my senior year i don't know what i'm
gonna do i don't know if i want to go or
not but um like they said i was gonna be
in the cafeteria i was like i'm not
gonna spend all this money
yeah i'm not doing that yeah but no i
get i mean because just going to prom is
just a thing you know it's like a thing
everyone does you go to prom and for it
to be like oh my company like makes me
very sad for high schoolers at that at
that time what do you think you would
have shown in that mcdonald's
all-american game um i haven't even
thought about what i would have shown i
just know how fun it would have been
like just even practicing and just
like like playing on tv like espn like
it was just been crazy really yeah y'all
and me watching all the games before me
so it would have been great graduation
didn't change though right like you saw
yeah we had a graduation yeah it was it
was on our football field so it was
pretty cool it rained but it was all
good yeah but it was still good yeah you
got the cap and gown
yeah yeah so i believe i read that
growing up you actually dreamed about
playing for calipari at kentucky
but then i guess because they ended up
seeing your potential late you're like i
want to be with a team that saw it it's
not really early yeah so like i mean how
how much did you want to be at kentucky
um when i grew up i was always watching
kentucky like anthony davis crying i
think towns like
deanna fox like malik monk like all of
those people i was always watching them
like that was where i wanted to go like
when i was younger i always said like i
want to go to kentucky like that's the
school i'm gonna go to but it's like
when i got older and teams started
recruiting me like i had office from
georgia
like auburn like lsu and when i started
getting office like that i'm like
kentucky like where you at you know what
i'm saying like
that they haven't offered me yet but
people tell me like you know blue bloods
come in late they don't really offer
this early i'm like why right and i'm
saying like what's your like what are
y'all not seeing so it was like when my
when my decision came it was like i'm
gonna go for somebody who's seen my
potential early and who really
really
really want me you know i mean i don't
want somebody who just
saw my ranking and saw all of this and
was like we gonna recruit him now like
nah i want somebody who's been watching
me since i was
in 10th grade 9th grade you know what i
mean so that's kind of the loyalty part
came into it a little bit totally but i
mean all things work out as they should
because you could argue that like
this maybe isn't even happening right
now if you had gone to yeah
you know oh my gosh we're kentucky fans
thinking damn we could have had your
voice
i know right but you you went you went
to the right place um but you are now
with tai tai you went to who went to
kentucky i think that when you played
them though he was hurt um he got hurt
like in the like first four minutes of
the game yeah so you didn't get the full
strength didn't get him at 4 00. he
didn't even get to talk trash about it
yeah i do i we won i i'm always going to
say that but you know just come back as
always he was hurting all of that but
yeah i'll take it up yeah
what makes high time special your new um
i just love how he always plays the
right way like he don't try to like
get out of his body and like do
do stuff he know he can't do you know i
mean like he's not gonna try to
score 30 and you know just he's capable
of scoring 30 of course but he's not
gonna like force it you know i mean like
he's real real chat real chill real real
encouraging he plays hard always making
the right plays he just lets the game
come to him so that's what i love about
it
what do you love about jalen green um
jalen green he's real i haven't played
with him yet but as i've seen like he's
real competitive he plays with that
little fire a little bit um and i like
that so just his ability to score his
ability to just do so much like
i can't wait to play with it now you
know where like jalen and josh you're
entering a real uh stylish team
are you gonna have to step up the fence
i mean i'mma try to but i ain't gonna be
on all of that you know what i'm saying
but i mean i'm gonna try to you're like
you're gonna do it you're away yeah i'm
gonna do it my way all right i got you i
know that on your chest you have forever
humble tatted right
how has that kind of guided your life
um
just through all the success and through
all the accomplishments not forgetting
where i came from not forgetting what
got me here not forgetting the people
who helped me get here so that kind of
just keeps me grounded in and always
always remind me to just treat people
the right way no matter no matter who
they are no matter who no matter how
famous or
um
how high up you get never never forget
where you came from
do you feel like that is something that
you will have to not remind yourself of
it but be very cognizant of as your life
continues to change um definitely
definitely just as as um
as the money comes and uh and playing on
tv every
every s some
however many days it's like a lot of
people are going to know you a lot of
people are going push your buttons a lot
of people are going to try to try to get
certain reactions out of you you just
got to remember like just to remain
yourself always treat people the right
way and just remain who you are
so i can tell you when you talk about
you know whether it's what happened with
orlando draft night or if it's you know
kentucky not seeing your potential early
that you have a very deep confidence in
your abilities and you believe yourself
to be the best or one of the best
how do you think that will manifest this
first year
in the nba
um
i think of the show really like
just my work ethic and just my
my attention and detail and my
unselfishness will really show this year
like
i feel like we're going to win some
games and i feel like i'm going to be a
big reason why
is being slighted something that you
feel like motivates you
um definitely um i like to prove people
wrong i like to
i like to um
what you call them doubters haters or
whatever i like to i like to prove them
wrong a little bit so
that that that's what kind of motivates
me but at the same time it's like you
can't let it like if you're not proven
wrong you can't let it affect you you
know what i'm saying so you gotta
remember that too yeah you still got to
live for you but just be aware of it
i'll prove him wrong i'm gonna let him
know for sure oh you're gonna let him
know you're gonna let it i believe that
as you should as you absolutely should
okay what will be success
for houston this season um i feel like
success
would be
um
a better season than last year honestly
um i feel like our goal would be to make
the playoffs but as as you see how the
west is stacked up um it's going to be
tough but it's definitely going to be a
goal that we're going to be working for
we're going to be trying to achieve but
ultimately i just feel like a better
season than last year and a trend a
trend in the right direction is
definitely what we're looking for so i
know who you're excited to defend but
what team are you most excited to play
um what team
um
i'm definitely excited to play the
warriors just because they just won the
finals and that dynasty is kind of
becoming like a
like like a thing so i just want to
really play them and see
see how that is and just be able to tell
my friends like yeah it's for real yeah
like they are really about that
you know i love talking to younger
basketball players because in so many
ways
you guys have been shaped by the new
style of the nba how did watching the
warriors watching steph watching clay
like shape how you play basketball um
it's like like when you see them play
you see how small they were playing you
see how many threes they were shooting
it's like and they were winning while
doing it so it's like teams are going to
go to that like teams are gonna be like
okay they won a championship doing it
now let me try now let me try now teams
are all doing it but just all in
different ways like you know the
warriors change the game forever like
threes is something that's gonna be a
part of the league forever and it's it's
gonna keep going up that way so yeah
like
watching that it just seems like you
have to be able to shoot like
like shooting is something that's
mandatory in today's game if you're not
seven foot or if you're not you know
what i mean it's still people out there
but
it's like it's real slim especially if
you're not
if you're shorter like shooting is
something that you have to be helping to
do and that's just something that i
focused on like growing up not knowing
how tall i would be not knowing any of
that just always focusing on being able
to shoot and that being a thing that
like people can check check off real
quick yeah but so you growing up
focusing on shooting the three what was
that a direct result of was it because
you saw them and how the game was going
or was it you know your dad telling you
to focus on that why did you um kind of
kind of both kind of because my dad told
me to focus on it and i didn't want to
limit myself and
and um i wanted to be able to do all
things you know i mean watching kevin
durant watching lebron and all those
type of guys like they don't have no
limits so i want to be like that okay
nice well before you go i mean i
definitely have to ask you about this
because our friend jackie out there told
us you are a
big atlanta rap fan yeah okay you gotta
tell me
top three atlanta rappers top three
that's easy
okay i'll do three that's gonna say five
but i went through i'll do five whatever
you want
you're like i'm in it
okay give me five five okay so um
atlanta all right we doing all the time
or like my personal favorite what do
y'all think we should do all the time or
his fave
i think all the time i think i'll tell
you you have to do all the time if i
forget some people they're gonna be mad
at me
okay i'm not gonna do no specific order
okay just your all-time five no okay um
favoritism is definitely in this by the
way okay but um i gotta i gotta go like
um outcast
um
jeezy
um
uh
this is tough i'm gonna go future okay
um that's three
um
i'm trying to think
um
i'm gonna go young thug okay
and for the fifth one i know i'm
forgetting somebody
um
i don't know about the fifth floor i
can't remember well i'm gonna say number
one you had to say outcast you passed
that test in my head i'm like how old is
he's you know is he gonna say i have
soundcast
i do have just like an overall music
question okay
so i'm dirty i'm like i listen to maybe
just like a little different music than
some of the younger guys
everyone did this favorite rapper's
thing with nba and people were saying
like nba young boy and like
i'm like i do not know
wanna be away song i don't think for
real i think maybe i do but i just don't
know what it is you don't heard one
before but you probably don't yeah
you're like putting it in your
headphones listening to it yeah i think
i got very specific
music taste and that is like just a
different thing that i that i haven't
gone to so who are some of the
who are the kids listening to that i
need to listen to i mean
ghana is definitely one of them i listen
to god okay listen again
okay you talking about people you don't
know about do you listen to babyface ray
okay that's another one i've like seen
him i have no idea i only see him
because he kind of has like some viral
videos and stuff right yeah
he's somebody i've started listening to
recently that i really like like but i'm
trying to think of somebody you wouldn't
know um
i don't know okay give back to me and
then i think i need to
know i'm gonna definitely think about it
you gotta relate to the kids these days
like everyone i'm listening to is like
old i need to expand my palette um any
twitter questions i'm not twitter
questions i have questions is a little
baby on the list
oh my bad but i was thinking more like
older but i i didn't want to forget
somebody in my past and then my dad be
like how are you forgetting yourself
yeah but little baby definitely would be
in my top five for sure
you didn't say ti
i was thinking tia but it's like
i don't know what is he i was really
focused on not missing nobody like
that's really should be in it you know
yeah i like
yeah yeah yeah yeah um okay people are
asking
if to hear some highs and lows from your
high school career people are asking to
hear highs and lows from your high
school career highs and lows from high
school um i would say
i had a lot of highs you know i'm saying
but
some of the lows would be like um
just just playing some of the players
who were
um considered better than me or playing
some of the players who were
um
just just how i went into it i feel like
i went into it wrong i feel like
sometimes i went into it kind of this is
when i was like younger like sophomore
maybe junior i think i went into a one
and a prove myself and wanted to wanted
to outplay them rather than going into
it ready to win the game and ready to
really impact my team and really win so
when i got when i became a senior and i
played against like apollo and chet and
the pangos camp it was like i really
want to win the game i don't want to
focus on this matchup because if i focus
on winning the game and taking care of
that everything else to take care of
itself so that's one lesson i learned
and also um
as i got highly highly rated people
playing at me people trying to get under
my skin and trying to just do little
stuff to just kind of throw me off it
was like i really laughed at it like
come on bro like
yeah yeah so it's like
like little stuff like that it's just
for like just always focus on winning
and always always keep the main thing
the main thing i would say do you talk
trash uh yeah he's like yeah
like what kind of trash talker are you
well i'm not the type to just go at you
first but like if you say something to
me i'm gonna be here the rest of the
game yeah rest of the game yeah not
stopping okay i like that is there
anyone you're excited to talk trash too
um
there's a lot of trash talkers in the
league so so many the best would
probably be i would probably say like
draymond green uh john marant
um
i don't know everybody talking they say
kevin durant is a real good trash talker
but he's he's kind of like that too he
won't say nothing if you don't say
nothing so i'm probably just leave him
alone
everybody just leave him alone bro i'm
not gonna give him any ammo yeah i would
just leave him alone but uh
yeah that was probably two guys i really
wanna you know seal it down so you you
know you just alluded to it talking
about penguin pangos with paulo and chet
when did you know like chet was a pro um
really watching them you know like when
like in high school watching his games
and just when i really played against
him i was like yeah he's going to be
good just because his ability to like
space the floor his ability to do
do so much and he's like he's tall as he
he's long as i don't know what so it's
like it's crazy so
like that that asset and people say he's
not strong and all of that like he's not
just weak you know i mean like playing
against him he's not just somebody you
just gonna bully like he's not soft he's
not none of that like
he's gonna get stronger as age comes and
like i feel like he'll be fine in the
nba it had to be weird for him
to like read all these articles about
himself and everybody talking about like
his body his durability him being weak
and him being like
there's more to that yeah was it weird
for you hearing people critique your
game you're like that's not right i'm
actually good at this yeah it's funny
it's like it kind of shows you um what
you want to showcase but at the same
time it's like when people talk about
like my ball handling and stuff like
that like i feel like that's something
that's going to come as i get older and
just get stronger but right now it's not
something that i'm going to just try to
show y'all like i'm not going to be out
here trying to look like steph curry
when that's not what i can do right now
like i'm not going to try to do that but
am i working on it yes will somebody say
he needs to work on this he needs to
work on this like how can you say i'm
not working on it you know what i mean
so it's like kind of thinking about that
but at the same time
doing stuff in the game i know what
helped my team win yeah yeah you know it
probably doesn't feel like it in this
moment but
for you being able to hear what people
say about you whether it's your ball
handing if they're talking about your
summerly performance whatever even
things that you dealt with on draft
night
i think in the long run having that
experience now really will help you
because you got like an instant crash
course into what it is like to be an nba
player and have all these lights on you
so in some ways i think it was yeah it's
gonna be beneficial definitely even like
my first two summer league games it was
like it wasn't my best games but
instantly people was like
man you know i'm saying saying crazy
stuff like it was to the point where i
had to just delete my social media like
i can't even like read this so it was
like i got to that point and this feel
like i'm glad i got to like
like feel that like now you know what i
mean i feel like it didn't affect me at
all but it was just like dang people
really saying this like yeah of two
summer league games like so it was like
it was just to deal with that was kind
of kind of beneficial oh all the
internet is is overreaction
and people talking about things they
don't like really know what they're
talking about i think that it's probably
best to like not pay attention to that
not get it any stock but to be aware
like okay i'm gonna prove this is what
they're saying but they're wrong and i
you know and i'm out to
prove that for sure um any other ones a
couple
personal goals for the year and your
goals for the rockets for the year
personal goals for the year and your
goals for the rockets for the personal
goals would be um of course winning
rookie of the year that's one of the
that's one person to go i feel like
every rook he's gonna say
um and team god just like i said like
trending in the right direction winning
more games in last year and showing uh
obvious growth you know what i mean and
for for overall making the playoffs like
that's gonna be our main goal that's
gonna be our main focus
um what player was your inspiration
growing up what player was your
inspiration growing up um lebron james
easily like he was he was
like around the age i was growing up
like he was he was that deal so
i had lebron posters in my room i was a
heat fan for that little stint then when
he left i threw all of it away it was
like then he went to the cavs and i was
a cavs fan was like lebron was somebody
i just always idolized and looked up to
have you had any interactions with him
nah no what do you think that first
conversation will be like or you feel
like it's going to happen on the court i
don't know i don't know how it's going
to be but i've never even seen him in
person
really yeah i've never seen lebron in
person oh wow okay when i was younger i
went to a hawks vs heat game just to see
lebron play you know what i'm saying but
he wasn't even he didn't play
he sat out him and dwayne wayne sat out
no yeah it was a hockey game
oh my gosh wow so you've never seen him
nope
okay so if you were to see him outside
of the basketball court right what would
you say
i mean i wouldn't be like no fan and i
don't know you know what i'm saying but
i'm definitely gonna be like that's
lebron i gotta gotta say something so
i'm gonna just probably tap them up and
be like
what's up um
i'm not gonna i wouldn't say nothing too
crazy but i'd definitely be like what's
up um you know i'll probably just say
what's up tap him up and keep it pushing
right now yeah but that was like
definitely like pull out my phone i just
talking lebron you know what i'm saying
like i'm definitely doing that good yeah
because you can't show it to him but you
can text your friends
oh i love that uh anymore um yeah we can
do this as the last one would you rather
dominate against lebron and steph or
chet and paulo would you rather dominate
against the promise to ever chat about
the bronze old school or the new school
lebron stuff definitely yeah definitely
what um what current nba players if any
have you gone to for like advice or
encouragement or like have helped you
along the way um it's a lot of people
from georgia there's a lot of people
that that have been in the gym with me
like while i was growing up like jordan
mcrae um
like lou williams um
like um i'm trying to think derrick
favors has told me told me some things
um
trying to think
um
kevin murphy
um it's kind of like older guys and kind
of guys who who are from georgia who
i've like played pick up wouldn't just
just been around always always teaching
me new things and just
encouraging me really good well hey i'm
very excited to watch you for the
rockets
you better put off for georgio okay
don't let me
down thank you so much for your time and
enjoy hot vegas i'm getting out of here
[Music]
you